bueno lo que sabemos es lo que se ha
aplicado el 'new york times' hablaba
según fuentes israelíes y
estadounidenses de que se podría tener
efectos por nueve meses y detener el
trabajo en esta planta nuclear hoy lo
que ha dicho desde la organización de
energía atómica local es decir que se
van a instalar nuevas centrifugadoras
mucho más potentes que las que estaban
actualmente lo que podrá poner a irán al
mismo nivel este tiempo que van a perder
van a poder ponerse a la par muy
rápidamente ellos han dicho que ya saben
cuál fue este estadio led eléctrico y
que ya tienen la capacidad la planta de
emergencia de emergencia para empezar la
operar pero aquí hay voces críticas
también ángel hay aquí el sector más
radical dice que se paren esas
conversaciones que deben continuar el
próximo miércoles en viena aunque el
ministro saríev ha dicho que eso sería
caer en la trampa de los israelíes país
al que acusan y que ellos no van a parar
esas conversaciones sin embargo también
dijo que habrá una venganza aunque suele
como sólo serán irán en estos casos
nunca
el tiempo y es que recordemos que este
no es el primer ataque a una planta
nuclear a esta misma ya había sufrido un
ataque en junio del 2020 una planta
externa donde también habían centros
jugadores y el pasado noviembre fue
asesinado quien se considera la cabeza
del programa nuclear iraní inbox en
parís haré así que ya se empieza a
hablar de qué tan infiltrado está el
programa nuclear iraní en este país